how do black and asian people relate to
each other because i have no concept of
that you know black and asian people get
along as long as it's not a situation
where black persons go in the grocery
store because it doesn't really matter
how much of a friend you are like you're
right
no no they're going to follow you
they'll follow you asians will yeah
they'll follow you they'll follow you oh
in the grocery store in the grocery
store but also though all those movies
where the black guys come in and shoot
up the grocery store probably has a lot
of those asian counter people escaping i
don't know those movies yeah
really i don't know did you just come
and shoot up the grocery store what
movie is that yeah i think you just made
it up bro
that might be the news it might be
here's a situation
the situation with asians me being prime
military and stationed in korea oh yeah
you have such a different perception
what what asians
hate about western civilization the most
is
having no respect for elders
you know what i'm saying when i was when
i was stationed in korea in the air
force that's one thing it didn't matter
what your financial status was whatever
you had a certain level of respect just
because that person was older than you
yeah you know what i'm saying no matter
where you from whatever and then when
they come over here and then they see
like and this is not just for black
people any kid like it's america just
america and they say you being
disrespectful to elders i think they
can't really they can't really connect
with that you know because i have some
really cool um korean friends that
because they know that my my background
in the asian community in korea they
know that i understand the things that
upset them there i got love yeah yeah
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two options
watch one this one or this one